all right now we've heard where to go
for valentine's day but what about the
gift you can't go wrong with a gift of
luxury for your galentine or valentine
and joining me to tell us more about
some fantastic finds is tracy butchko
from max pond thanks for joining us
today thank you for having me you
brought me some gifts thank you so much
i appreciate it yeah some really pretty
beauty now we love max pond because you
can get the ultimate in luxury uh you
can get labels like gucci louis vuitton
chanel
for a fraction of the price right and
even coach michael kors kate spade we're
all over for every price point okay
let's talk about some of these bags here
this is a beautiful louie here that i'm
holding
how do you know
something is
real versus a knockoff so we have a lot
of experience in the store first of all
i would say our people are our pe most
prized piece but we also offer entropy
which is a third-party authentication
that will give you a card that goes with
your purchase that's uh stating the bag
is authentic not just max pond but
entropy also this one is beautiful a lot
of times you can tell like with the
hardware yeah there's a lot of things
that you can see if you know what to
look for now you guys are having a
special event for
valentine's day or galentine's day tell
us what you guys have going on so from
the 11th through the 14th of february
we're going to have special pricing
available for anyone that wants to stop
in and we're going to have a little
bubbly and some sweets too if you just
want to come down and be surrounded by
some beautiful things now of course i'm
drawn to the purses i love i love this
chanel this is beautiful but you also
have jewelry which is perfect for
valentine's day talk about some of the
pieces that you guys have it's not just
about the bags right we have a really
gorgeous selection of jewelry and from
all price points we have something like
this beautiful necklace which is about a
thousand dollars to this five and a half
carat cushion cut diamond
and this beautiful
cartier
chronograph
that is beautiful and of course
you buy items too absolutely we're happy
to take something off your hands yeah
and that's good for the environment
because we're recycling here we're up
cycling and that's good for the planet
tell everyone where they can find you
guys we are at 60 40 west sahara the
corner of sahara and
and jones and we are open seven days a
week from nine to six all right well i'm
gonna just go ahead and take this and
i'll send it back to you jillian
well get ready to shop and find